stream I've had both twitch and just 24
chat uh open so that not to reopen it
the next day it's amazing he was
described and once again I understand
I'm slightly taking it out on one you
know unsuspecting user who probably
isn't even there right now so I'm doing
this behind this back potentially which
really isn't which really isn't what I
intended but good cash was described as
uh and the whole situation was described
as a reality check to somebody who
farmed 2500s
the man started eight out of eight on
board one in the Olympiad
you beat Carolina farming 2500s excuse
me yeah this is uh this is crazy yeah
crazy talk this is an absolutely
horrendous overreaction to it uh we have
an anti-martial where Magnus uh weirdly
you know he makes the absolute main move
in this position which in his hands is I
mean not a novelty but a bit of a
surprise because he's been very much
uh in the camp of not playing B5 before
I'm guessing believing these positions
to be uh difficult to play
or a win and just kind of they they do
tend to simplify quite a bit both the
positions after G4 and arguably even
even these ones but today he seems to be
happy with it he goes A4 B4 A5 not even
any of the Rook B8 silliness that uh
camera did recently against Wesley
but the very straight straight forward
D6 Fabi doesn't go D3
uh
my guess as to why is probably because
Magnus himself is a very very serious
player of this line and I guess he
thinks Magnus will know C3 will be eight
H3 I don't think that works out quite as
well as we like so maybe you don't have
very useful passes apart from Rook B8
that wins Vincent chose yeah he's he's
played a type of pass move in the game
slightly different position of course
and I guess the question here for Fabi
um in the game position is whether D4 in
one go is possible uh H6 Now by Magnus
he's basically saying okay you can play
D4 and we're going okay default
instantly blitzed out by uh Fabi and
yeah it feels like whites if you don't
challenge the setup now what does the
chief well a lot simply and Black's not
really chosen a typical Spanish reply
without access to Knight C3 it will be
actually kind of difficult to smoke this
uh this night out you know it does
appear to be quite stable only four can
be supported by Bishop of five if you go
like bg2 you have to at least calculate
Bishop before in some positions probably
not right here but in some positions
definitely it could become playable uh
bc3 bc3 already on the board in the
meantime and just to finish our
conversation about
um about gambits uh if I understand our
chart correctly D5 here D6 C3 G5 eg5 E4
has been seen before and uh live on
among amongst others have has played
this but yeah Magnus goes for something
else
uh Fabi actually took the Knight and not
the pawn here
um
I guess because if you if you try doing
the same uh the light only four could
immediately perhaps be driven away even
though F5 is not a four square so I'm
I'm curious why this is unplayable maybe
it is playable and the model is just
like there should be seven more which I
can also very easily believe uh because
E5 will be a nice Square for this piece
which it immediately assumes
looks okay for black
yeah it looks okay for black although
you you could also imagine why becoming
a little bit worse if you don't what
we'll say better if you don't have a
good reply to Knight C4 next month still
feels like the onus is on black to prove
the equality uh like you say no C4 Fabi
versus Magnus the maneuver we were
expecting did happen and Fabi reacted in
a very concrete manner he went Bishop G3
and F4
and this now I assume considering going
in with E5 because generally you don't
want to weaken UEFA Pawn like this
without
having a very concrete idea how to
justify it yeah I guess that's an
argument for kind of maintaining the
tension with me such as Bishop C2 but
then does black break out somehow with
D5
um yeah that's one thing if he breaks I
kind of hesitate to mention it but it is
a pawn
yeah I mean queen G3 uh I guess we're
not very boring yeah
I apologize for doubting him for about
three seconds uh he did repeat once but
then uh yeah well Magnus
very much on point today yeah nice spot
by the Norwegian
so those variations we're mentioning uh
very relevant
um and once again thank you to to Jack
Hound who gave us an opportunity to be
slightly ahead of the curve here and to
start discussing it before Magnus put it
on the board uh Fabi did something uh
very very odd uh the position wasn't
really it wasn't great but it wasn't
really that bad and he thought for a bit
and played Bishop C3 Bishop B3 C2 here
which sort of loses on the spot and not
very not in a very difficult fashion
either
like extremely findable sequence of
moves which I yeah it's very difficult
for me to explain starts with queen D5
which you cannot possibly blunder
because yeah I guess he wants to play
with it soon
and then you just attack the pawn on D4
and Win It
okay and the only calculation I guess
you would need to do is he takes F6 Rook
to fix D4 no I think the problem is I
don't even understand what he means
against this to be honest okay this is
even more simple yeah because I think
what you're saying is also winning like
room before you cannot take on E8
because this is made so you have to play
the Queen somewhere and this also looks
utterly winning from like are there any
ways to complicate the issue even
slightly yeah 25 played in the meantime
your magnets is not going to is not
going to miss it I don't think yeah okay
let's start yeah I
let's try to figure out if Fabio already
sees what's happened or not it's hard
for him to judge I mean he he does have
a reasonably good poker face but
like liberation of all the normal moves
like my page five is fine but white is
very much alive after Knight H5 Ruby G8
is a massive Advantage for black group
before you kinda reside because and he's
a plated yeah and the problem is yeah
you just don't continue from here
because this Falls with the tempo and
then the Night Comes to you for
absolutely collapsing all of your
counter play and you're left with these
really ugly pieces which make no sense
together well this really is going to
end very soon there's not very much here
to to discuss why we did find a way to
uh you know generate one active move
because after Knight H5 for instance he
will have the access to uh
division B3 even this is nothing yeah
but like between the seven and uh
just everything's falling falling yeah
this is not this is not really
any kind of serious content play at all
you know it's
completely fine but Magnus likes to
finish with a bit of artistic Flair when
he can
um oh I'm just being told that Rook D2
is also good immediately yeah I was
going to say can we find anything as
well yeah can we find some pretty
checkmates
somehow maybe Rook D2 is the best way to
start
decision here he's gone Knight E4 he
actually like he does this in one of two
ways
either if he does find it he goes very
much playing for the gallery he goes for
something beautiful and exciting and
crowd-pleasing or if you can't find it
he just says okay I will win some
technical end game because Knight E4
like in order for white not to resign
here you have to take only four three
times
like everything else will lose your
material because this is a thread this
is a thread
position is collapsing so what he's
saying to Fabi is how enjoyable do you
do will you find the experience of
continuing to play the same game
which is probably borderline lost
without the pawn on C7 frankly yeah it's
a very difficult ending without the
policies itself maybe you can save you
know I don't know three out of ten or
something but you're going to hate life
even there and with the potency seven
still alive it's just like very very
dead
they just give you maybe a semblance of
Hope someone
yeah
um so yeah go on a while at least yes
yeah yeah and he'll actually gone for it
I I was wondering if you will even
you know continue but I guess he doesn't
want to give my satisfaction of winning
in 25 moves yeah so they'll play for a
bit but I really don't think we need to
be covering this we know the result we
know sort of the broad outlines of how
it will be won so it's not really
all that important to uh show this we'll
show when the game ends
so yeah and now uh there's a pin along
the C file the only way not to lose uh
material immediately I think is to play
before but unfortunately we go Bishop D5
and wherever the Knight goes the
simplest is just to play Vision before
take on A5
and I don't think you actually continue
two down one down maybe you can convince
yourself to continue two down you don't
really continue
yeah too much because yeah it's Child's
Play to convert yeah this pin is Just
Deadly over
yeah otherwise there should 45 just wins
a full piece so
yeah I think we'll see a Fabi resign
isn't it definitely no point uh kind of
continuing here major arrivals in this
fashion this is never fun
yeah you can see on both the body
language uh on the body language of both
players while they expect it to not last
too much longer no 455 as you
highlighted and I think this
exaggeration we're likely to see yeah
you can choose like you can also take on
A5 with the real Captain ib6 but I think
taking the Rooks off and then winning
the 495 is uh much cleaner yeah not
allowing white any kind of Rook c87
chair counter play it's still not really
counter play but why give white anything
that could be mistaken for counterfeit
uh looking a lot more manageable and he
does have a you know a bit of a run-up
uh
five rounds to go a point in a and a
half behind the leader and and yeah it
looks like they're signing they're
signing this course should scare yeah if
I finally resigns unsurprising there
really wasn't very much to play for
anymore